[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to Sweetwater
secrets your go-to source for all things
Riverdale
I'm your host Liana Galera and I am so
pumped because it has been 153 days heck
yes I have been counting since we last
reunited with those ridiculously
attractive residents of Riverdale now
each week I will be bringing you
exclusive interviews from the cast both
before every episode as well as
immediately afterwards so this is gonna
be your go-to place to completely freak
out over all things
Riverdale we're gonna have a lot of fun
in season two but first let's take a
look back at where we left off in season
1 now as you will recall when we last
saw our Riverdale residents Archie and
his father wanted to meet up for a
little meal at where else pops chocolate
shop but of course what was supposed to
be a sweet father and son chat over a
couple milkshakes turned into absolute
turmoil let's take a look
[Music]
no not Fred Andrews take all of the
milkshakes take my pearls take anything
you want but do not take the one sane
parent in Riverdale away from me plus he
is the hottest DILF on TV and I don't
know what I'll do with myself we have no
idea who that hooded person was that
attacked Fred Andrews but as Jughead
said and his haunting voiceover this
attack was anything but random and I can
say that we will be picking up exactly
where we left off in the season two
premiere
it's called chapter 14 a kiss before
dying which is oh so cryptic and I don't
know if I can handle it but I do know
that I just got back from a trip up to
the end Coover Canada on the Riverdale
set where I caught up with all of your
favorites and here is what archiekins
aka KJ alpha promised me that we will
find out about season 2 hey KJ hey how
you do it yeah Archie's going through a
lot in season 2 he's got a lot of
emotional turmoil going on how would you
describe his mindset throughout the
beginning of the second season beginning
the second season I think it's the first
time we see a we see a completely
different side of Archie a what first
seeing like the the dark side about you
we never got to see him in the first
season so that was really exciting when
I first read that for the first episode
of the season 2 I was really excited to
see that we were going in that direction
but it sure you can TP get to be a lot
darker you can expect to we dive into
the relationships a lot more I think
Bishop Archie and Veronica with again
with Fred being shot there's so many
different parts of their relationship
that they're exploring and that they're
finding out about each other and
different like kind of characteristics
that are coming out and then both that
they're learning about with each other
and I think I think the same with Jackie
and Betty as well a lot of trials to be
to be had for sure now you guys that was
just a teeny tiny little part of all the
Riverdale goodies that I will be
bringing you all season long so keep it
locked
interviews from your favorite stars as
well as episode breakdowns of the most
jaw-dropping moments now be sure to hit
subscribe to e t--'s youtube channel and
give this video like if you want to see
more then hit the comments or chat with
me on Twitter about everything that
you're hoping to see from Riverdale
season 2 now I will be talking to you
guys after the season 2 premiere to chat
about the episodes steamiest moment as
well as the moment that everyone is
going to be talking about thanks so much
for tuning in guys and I'll see you
later for more Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
you